when you get to see
um
some of them reach these levels of
success and you don't understand the
struggle like you show those pictures of
him when you guys used to party together
and as fun as it may look you'd be
surprised what people are going through
like internally right it's like he came
here to party but look at where he is
now you know putting things aside you
know putting your priorities first and
putting yourself first and to me like a
reaction like that I know it's like men
shouldn't cry and show weakness but like
seeing that you can't help but respect
you know it's like shout out to you for
putting the work the grind you know went
to go see a fan in the wheelchair like
it's those little things that are are
character builders for people